- This is what I just want,
this is what a twenty-something year old
looks like pregnant.
(laughing)
Because I never experienced that.
- Well, I thought it
would dress up for you,
this is all for you.
- You look beautiful.
- Thank you.
- Oh my gosh.
- I'm so happy for you.
- Thank you.
- Are, how's it going?
- It's going really well.
I mean,
- Yeah?
- it's, it's, it's weird
- I'm happy for you.
- and amazing and everything in between.
- Yeah?
Mine were horrible.
- Were they?
- Yeah, yeah.
So I always, every time I see someone
that looks like they're happy,
I'm like good for you.
- Any day that I'm not feeling
like I'm gonna throw up
everywhere is a fantastic day.
- It's a, okay,
you're a silver lining
kind of girl, I like it.
So were,
(laughing)
so were you someone
who wanted to know the gender right away?
- Yes, I was,
- Me too.
- I was like,
I'm not gonna get all
yellow and gray clothing.
- Nope.
- Like I need to know
- Yes.
- But you know you--
- And for names, I just wanted to--
- And for names!
- Well, I guess I ended up with
androgynous names, but yeah.
- Oh, I like that.
- Yeah.
- No, I mean, I was like,
I have to find out, I have to find out.
So I waited and waited
and then you do the test
and they're like five to 10 days,
which is eternity.
- It seems like a lifetime.
- And so I got a call one
morning and they're like,
"Oh, we got your results in."
And I grabbed my boyfriend,
we found out we were so excited
and I was wrong, my guess
was wrong by the way.
And I, we were like, let's call our moms.
Like, those are the first
people we should call
and I call my mom I'm
like, mom, good morning.
Guess what we're having?
And she's like,
"Don't tell me eggs benedict."
And I was like, what, no the baby,
and she said, "Oh, I thought
you meant for breakfast."
And I was like, no, it's a boy.
- Don't tell me it's a guess
a breakfast guessing game.
- I was like I hope this
isn't just eggs benedict,
I was like I hope it's a baby boy.
- I'm working very hard,
I hope a human comes out.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
- Well, have you been digging
into all the parenting books?
I know with my first kid, I like was like,
everybody gave me
everything, first of all,
but then it kind of just sat there.
I like maybe read one.
- I've been reading a lot.
- Yeah?
- I mean, I love to read
- Me too.
- and I feel like I have so
much time to read right now.
- Yeah.
- So I've been reading
a ton of books in general,
but especially like pregnancy
books, parenting books
but I did,
I looked over at my
nightstand the other night
and it was like a book
about alien encounters
and What To Expect When You're Expecting
and I was like, what are, what's my,
what's my mood lately, is this is okay.
- It's a weird, yeah.
- Yeah, it's a very, I am,
I have two different
mindsets these days, I guess,
aliens and babies.
- It feels like an alien
growing in you.
- Oh.
- I always felt like,
I don't know if you're you're young,
I don't know if you ever saw Spaceballs.
(laughing)
- Yes.
- Like where the thing comes out
and it's hello my baby.
Anyway,
(laughing)
I'm a very weird person.